good morning Hank it's Tuesday so in the
20th century about as many people died
from smallpox as currently live in the
United States of America I bring this up
because I don't think it's a rational to
be terrified of infectious diseases they
are terrifying but then again for the
rest of human history no one will die
from smallpox because we eradicated it
like the beginning of the Wikipedia page
for smallpox is smallpox was an
infectious disease so don't
underestimate humans when it comes to
kicking microbial but today I want to
talk about Ebola and what shouldn't
terrify us about it and also what should
so quick update currently three people
have contracted Ebola in the u.s.
Nigeria which had 20 infections was just
declared ebola-free by the World Health
Organization good work Nigeria but there
been about 10,000 total reported cases
in Guinea Liberia and Sierra Leone also
we know that number is low because
there's a lot of underreporting and as
this graph indicates the rate of
infection is not even beginning to level
off and that is terrifying the current
outbreak here in the United States is
not terrifying for one thing infection
controls are good enough that the
disease won't spread widely and for
another the survival rate so far is over
80% thanks to excellent supportive care
whereas in West Africa it's closer to
30% but as long as the outbreak is
worsening in West Africa there will be
other outbreaks around the world
regardless of whether we revoke the
visas of people traveling from affected
countries and regardless of whether
every nation on earth checks every
international traveler for fever
henk microorganisms just aren't very
well informed when it comes to the
borders of nation states and if we're
going to enjoy the many benefits of
globalization inexpensive Argentinian
beef and our Big Macs West African
chocolate in our Hershey's Kisses roses
from Kenya clothes from Bangladesh if
we're going to have all that stuff we're
also going to leave in a global health
community we like to imagine that deadly
infectious diseases like cholera or
malaria happened to other people too
like poor people who live far away from
us but Ebola reminds us just how false
that us/them dichotomy is like better
healthcare infrastructure in Liberia is
not just good for the health and
productivity of Liberians it's also good
for the health and productivity of all
humans and then there's the non Ebola
effects of Ebola like as Bill Gates has
pointed out the collapse of public
health care systems in Sierra Leone and
Liberia and Guinea has probably led to
more deaths from non Bhalla causes than
from Ebola harvests are being affected
as is
every segment of these countries
economies and we're probably at the
beginning of the outbreak I mean the
World Health Organization is estimating
that by December there could be between
five and ten thousand new cases of Ebola
per week now I understand the impulse to
try to cut these countries off from the
rest of the world but experts agree that
will lead to more Ebola around the world
not less as we've already seen from the
insufficiently robust international
response to the initial outbreak so what
are we going to do well the World Health
Organization's current plan is 70 70 60
although grammatically I would say that
it's more 60 70 70 the idea is that
within sixty days
70% of Ebola patients will be isolated
and 70% of burials will be safe that's
going to require tremendous community
outreach and lots more hospital beds
which is going to be very expensive like
up to a billion dollars a month and also
will require a lot of staff the heroes
of this story will be the people who
build and run those clinics and they
will be American and Cuban and Botswana
nande there will be many many West
Africans who work together to isolate
and treat Ebola patients that is hugely
courageous work and it is done on behalf
of all humans it will eventually be
effective and the Ebola outbreak will
eventually be contained but at a very
high cost but Hank I hope that we might
learn from this disaster that when it
comes to communicable diseases in
today's world threats to the health of
any humans are threats to the health of
all humans I'll see you on Friday